et le césar de la meilleure actrice est
attribuée adèle haenel dans les
combattants c'est son deuxième césar en
deux ans après celui du second rôle pour
suis à l'an 2014
elle a laissé aussi nommé en révélation
féminine pour naissance des pieuvres
pour l'apollonide ont là aussi plus l'an
dernier dans leur camp nou lé tro
d'andré téchiné avec le guillaume canet
on le retrouvera en 2015 dans safari
d'un groupe canadien guy lambin dans les
ordres de l'entraîneur et elle sera sur
la scène du théâtre des quartiers d'ivry
gymnase au 22 mars dans la trilogie
mayenburg
bonsoir enfin ça fait un peu un drôle
d'effet voilà moi je peins simplement je
voudrais remercier l'équipe du film mon
partenaire kevin azéris à qui je
souhaite vraiment une très belle
carrière également thomas kayal
réalisateur voilà qu'est ce qu'il ya je
vais pas leur dire ça et non je sais
aussi une pensée ce soir pour andré
téchiné
voilà parce que
j'ai fait un film avec lui et ça a été
une expérience incroyable
donc je voudrais remercier je pense que
au delà de des tournages et des
rencontres il ya des gens qui restent et
je pense que voilà ça c'est beau aussi
l'équipe qu'on se constitue
tout au long de sa vie et et voilà je
sais pas trop quoi dire d'autre c'est
donc ça fait vraiment un drôle d'effet
merci